hello I'm Gavin welcome to the slow mo
guys you've joined me in the middle of a
Dallas wrecking yard
for a long time we've been a big fan of
these three blokes so we're very excited
to be here to promote season 2 at the
Grand Tour Dan's late arias check it out
what do you think of this it's my hobby
we bought an RV yeah why mine I was
thinking we're shooting at least remote
locations I also want to chill out like
a home base from this road trip American
dream and all that absolutely make sense
to me
so you're saying a grand tour right yeah
grand saucer be a crime not to do
something involving cars okay what looks
good with slow motion in cars what
annihilate in the hell out of them smash
never yeah any thoughts I was thinking
how about a 4 ton wrecking ball and a
huge crane usually used to smash up
massive buildings yeah so it should make
a sizable ding in a car I mean I think
it's slightly over token saying but
anyway we've got some old bangers we're
gonna annihilate and how about we test
it on a wall first you've gotta make
sure we've got a good wrecking ball yeah
benchmark yeah Miley Cyrus that's big
yeah I wasn't messing around
this is 9,000 pounds or more than four
metric tons of pure heft big on fat
cranes swinging it in yeah so we're
gonna hit the wall from behind this
actually a real brick wall solid it's
got some supports on the back obviously
they'll do nothing against this though
this is coming useful as a blast sure
I'm gonna hug this as close as possible
a second dude triggering too violent
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
acted like it was nothing just tore
through it like a piece of paper like
Lego yeah all right so I think we're
ready to put the cars in yeah that was a
good test we're ready our victim
a real American car isn't it victim
number one honking color Oh like Miss
Daisy tan vom evoke definitely involves
vomit somewhere it does 100% so we're
gonna absolutely rail it just right
there hit I think if we hit it low it's
more likely to shift so we'll give it
maximum beans and get the hell out the
way
[Music]
oh just swept it right over brain it's
like it's like you just got a broom and
we're not this
buckled that tire look at that
wait what do you see what's happened is
it's hit the rear of the car and this
this tire has dug into the ground
oh it pulled the tire off the wheel yeah
it ripped the tire off the wheel and
it's caused the back of the car to go
out and look this this tire officer
didn't have as much weight over it so
it's span it around the back oh man
see now here's your problem how are you
gonna get in the car now because the
handles broke how you gonna pick up
chicks I mean you could drive it sure oh
how you gonna clean up girls if they
can't get in guys hefty you wanna see if
the other door opens and you can get in
the driver's looks like you've pranked
it what happened here well funny story
all right let's give a let's have a
cheeky look at that foot shall we
I'm up for it oh you know what though
wrecking ball is absolutely fine window
go it's all tablecloth whips the window
it now the cars just like moving from
one place to the other what's
interesting is that even though the area
of impact is you know the size of the
front of the wrecking ball it drags in
so much extra material so the dent is
like twice the size er this is dragging
door and it just bashed the whole car a
phrase see you later
look at that so you see there where the
where the roof now is becoming kinked
and being like dragged down its crease
its flinging off all the paint
oh wow that's so neat shipping off in
those lines there's an element of
difference to this car yeah that one in
the fact that there's no door pillar Oh
interesting yeah the last one we hit
down here this one if we raised the ball
maybe a foot get more sort of crumpled
edge in the top and less moving of the
hole ha so we're gonna completely change
the angle of which we hit in the car so
maybe just smash through the top of
there all right
really we don't ever really know what's
gonna happen we're learning all the time
so experiment is it experiment what do
you think he ever drops the ball on his
job
but such a delay it really is
Oh
here he comes
I thought that might happen because
we're hitting it from the top I thought
if the roofs strong enough it will flip
the car
just straight in the window cool you see
the way the back part blast yeah with
you look guys just like almost pushing
it into the floor dragging it along way
worse a big t-bone
look at that that glass is now just
aerial glitter I like how the glass is
pretty much stationary but the car is
actually being shoved aside fast at me
glasses here horrible that bend in the
tires in the back that that's impression
so impressive how strong the roof is the
fact they held on and was and dragged it
you wouldn't want to have been in that
one know it that the mirror didn't even
get touched it missed them it must have
missed the mirror by about an inch
are there some coins what we're heavies
I need some changes you see there's your
problem
what it's upside down it's on its side
now though yes
hard to move how are we gonna move it
should be wrecking ball wrecking ball
[Music]
there it goes
[Music]
so it looks like one more hit oh
goodness a shockingly sturdy the
underside of a car yeah I mean it's just
I think that's where all the strength is
so the fact that it it just brushed off
with the wrecking ball and all the force
went into flipping the car also I think
it's less sturdy on its side than it is
with the wheels on the floor so it's
more like it's no longer bottom heavy
yeah so that's uh there's some good
swinging yeah how do you feel about
dropping I like dropping let's do some
dropping so we've hit the bottom of why
we've hit the side yeah well now we'll
just let gravity do the work right on
the front so you know Darius just pull
it all the way up push the emergency
release and drop it basically just
dropping the equivalent of a small
elephant onto the bonnet
yeah a female African elephant yeah all
right specific
oh that well it just landed in the car
parked in the car
it's just parked in it you know what
that hit the ground so hard it shook the
camera look at this look at this camera
shake like a joint whoa like a joint
space where like you know films in like
the dust if there was a cup of water on
the floor
it would have been t-rex like like got
like Godzilla sniper GoPro just said
that we could have killed that GoPros
amazing it survived 9,000 pounds Oh side
window burst it was the other side that
went really deep in the car I'm
convinced the wrecking ball actually
just hit the ground there yeah yeah I
feel like we should try and hit it again
it hit it right here sorry straight onto
the bonnet yeah okay where's the
steering wheel ah it's in the seat look
at the steering wheel would be in your
legs look just popped out this just like
oh that's the destruction we wanted
right goodness me judo and carmakers say
oh we couldn't fit a bigger and bigger
engine in yes you could I don't think a
window is it mean ever been more smashed
you know I only say you take a brick to
the window yeah but this is about the
size and width of the window the middle
of it there we're actually landed it's
turned all the glass back to sand yeah
it's now powder I couldn't have been
more centered on the engine [ __ ] what
you gotta remember is there's an engine
there there's like there's a solid chunk
of melt in the way not mucking about
yeah see that you see a wrecking ball is
rolling away oh that was a lovely amount
of destruction so satisfying he wrecked
some cars oh it turns into paper doesn't
it just like nothing was let's see where
it gets its name yeah yeah I love this
wrecking ball can we keep it how about
we take it with us I mean can you fly
with a 9,000 pound ball of metal
imagine the excess baggage fees for that
they just let you pay for the whole
flight probably just buy the plane
hopefully you enjoyed that video feel
free to subscribe to the slow mo guys
and make sure you check out new episodes
of the Grand Tour every Friday with
Amazon Prime we'll see you next time yes
fun what time's your flight I'm not fun
oh you oh you love it mine's pretty I'm
gonna go back to the hotel
see when I meet where you going about
hotel now I'm gonna have a shower
probably chill out for a bit your shower
in the RV here oh dear okay all right
well let me know you get back to those
hours I'll see you in a bit sounds good
thousand frames
Oh laughing blood yeah